All right, we are live, guys. Look who I
have here with me. Robert Spencer.
People couldn't believe people were like
couldn't believe that I managed to get
you on this show. Well, thank you so
much, Robert. Thank you for being here.
>> Happy to be here. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Well, I I we before we uh we
went live, I was basically just talking
about Robert's book and how much I
admire it, but I'm going to talk about
more like I've already t mentioned this
book a couple times on the show uh did
Muhammad exist, but because the title
right now is about Iran and Israel, I'm
going to mention this at the end of the
show. And also guys, please make sure
that you check Robert's website. The
link is in the description, uh
Jihadwash. I mean a lot of you guys know
already Robert's website but it's a
really good source of information so
make sure that you don't miss out on and
your socials Robert is also on the
website as well right your Facebook your
Twitter everything yes okay so Robert um
again thank you so much for coming on
the show I'm so honored um I just um I'm
really fascinated to know I want to know
about your views regarding the recent
events on between the Islamic Republic
Again, I call it the Islamic Republic
because I don't like to call it Iran
because when I say Iran, I'm referring
to the Iranian people and I don't think
it's fair to say Iran versus Israel
because it's not the Iran versus Israel,
it's the Islamic Republic versus Israel.
The Iranian people are are more and more
uh becoming fans of Israel, united with
Israel, and they consider Israel's
attack on the regime an attack on their
oppressors, not not an attack on Iran
itself. So that's why I I if I keep
saying Islamic Republic or the regime,
that's the reason. But I do want to see
because I saw that you were calling out
a whole bunch of people regard with the
12-day war. You're carrying the calling
out the fake news, the Islamic
Republic's propaganda regarding how that
war went. Um and you were I think you
were making, if I'm correct, you were
making fun of the people who were trying
to twist the narrative to try to look
like the Islamic Republic won that war.
Is that correct? Like can you tell us
your views about it? because I want to
also ask about your predictions going
forward after we go over that.
>> Yeah, you know, if I recall correctly,
there were uh some people in the Iranian
regime who were saying that they had won
and in a certain sense you can
understand that because his Baha said
the same thing. The uh the guy who is uh
who what's his name? The the head of his
>> No, not the not the dead one. The one
that replaced him. Uh is it
>> Oh, the walking the walking dead one.
>> I think his name is.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes.
>> And anyway, he was saying uh for us for
for us to survive was the victory. And
that's true because the jihad doesn't
end. This is what Westerners don't
understand. They think this is going to
be something where they sit down at a
table and sign a treaty and it'll all be
over. The jihad never ends. So in so far
as the Islamic Republic survived, they
did win, but otherwise they suffered
terrible losses and they might be on
their way to destruction from, as you
noted, the hatred that their own people
have for the regime. And there's so the
regime is so unpopular in Iran today
that we can hope that it's on its last
legs.
>> Right? So in Iran we have a saying we we
say
meaning that a Shia will never um admit
defeat and it's kind of like the monthly
Python sketch where the guy is like this
is nothing but a scratch as no matter
how much like and they actually admitted
they're like you know what if you defeat
us then we have become murderers and we
have won and if you don't defeat us then
we have won so we it's it's a win-win
for us in in any way. So,
>> well, you know, Armen, that's a very
important point because that's how the
jihad armies have won throughout the
centuries. They set up this win-win
situation. If you win in the in this
world, you get the booty, you get the
women, you get the property of the
unbelievers. And if you lose, you get
the [__] in paradise,
>> right?
>> You win either way.
>> Either way.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um so what do you there's a
lot of anti-Israeli narratives is being
spread all over the world right now and
as successful especially around the Gaza
situation but also regarding Israel's uh
attempt to regime and I do think it's an
attempt for regime change in Iran which
we Iranian people are actually hoping
that we they are successful at it many
of us here and there are also many
Iranians in the chat right now that are
um that are hoping that Israel are
successful in helping the Iranian people
do the regime change. You know, the
regime change will be done by the
Iranian people, but we do need outside
help because we don't have we're not the
Iranian people are not armed, right? But
the it's really difficult because as
successful as Israel is when it comes to
military and operations and intelligence
operations, they're losing the
information war. And I don't know if you
could describe the all the forces right
now around the world that are uniting um
against Israel and do you think that
matters to Israel? Do you think that it
does cause some damage and on its
success and why is it that so we have
obviously the the Islamic forces against
Israel? That's obvious. and also the
leftist forces that's also obvious
against Israel but now we also have the
rise of many people on the right against
Israel joining this uh joining this
force and first of all do you think it
matters or Israel will just do its thing
regardless and if it does matter why is
this happening and what can we do about
it
>> matters a great deal and it's already
delayed the victory that Israel would
have won and could have won in Gaza and
imperiled Israel's situation in the long
term. It's a clearly a planned concerted
effort because like take for example uh
the charge of genocide which is false.
There the population in Gaza has
increased since the war began. There's
no genocide in Gaza. But not only is
this taken for granted all over the
world, but it was planned from the
beginning. For example, Zohan Mdani, the
guy who's going to be the next mayor of
New York City, he said in November 2023
when the Israeli offensive in Gaza had
barely started and hardly anything had
happened at all and because it was
several weeks before they even went in
and after October 7th and Mandani
already was charging them with genocide.
It was a clearly planned effort that
took advantage of what happened on
October 7th in order to wage a worldwide
propaganda offensive against Israel.
Makes a very big difference because
without international public opinion,
Israel can't move. The uh
proof of that was shown by the Biden
administration when they held up weapon
shipments to Israel because it had
become such an unpopular cause,
particularly on the left. They were
afraid they would lose the election,
which of course they did and that it
would be in part because of their
support for Israel. So they tried to
play both sides against the middle,
light the candle at both ends and uh
hamstring Israel's ability to wage the
war while
maintaining public support for Israel,
funding Iran. You know, Biden sent 20
billion dollars to Iran and that's that
is to the Islamic Republic and
unfortunately not to the people. and the
uh
>> Gazins got 10 100 million and that's
Hamas because there isn't any way to
distinguish between Hamas and the Gazins
as we have seen with the aid
controversies and the fact that Hamas
appropriates the aid that comes in. Uh
Biden says I'm going to send $100
million to Gaza for humanitarian aid.
That means he's funding Hamas. So you
have that as a result of the propaganda
offensive that put the Democrats in a
corner and made them think we have to
abandon Israel in order to maintain any
kind of viable uh footing in the
election.
It didn't work, but it shows the power
of this propaganda.
But uh would you agree that it's not
just the Democrats because Trump also
stopped the 12-day war from succeeding
right when Israel was about to do the
final blow and also potentially they
were about to take out not because
Israel right at the beginning the few
hours at right at the beginning came out
and destroyed all all of the main
military officials of the RGC. It was
beautiful. It was like a miracle. It was
unbelievable. And then at the end of the
12- day war, they were about to go with
the main politicians and potentially
including Harmony and Trump stopped it.
And I actually before the 12- day war
ended, like right in the beginning of
the few hours, I told my Persian
audience on my on my Persian on my
Iranian audience channel that I the
Islamic Republic is over unless Trump
comes and stops this from stops Israel.
And a lot of people are like telling me
like what are you talking about Armen?
Why would Trump do that? I'm like I
think Trump is going to stop it. And my
prediction came true and Trump stopped
it. So so this information where like do
you agree that it's also on the
Republican side that basically we could
have we could have lived in a world
right now without that Islamic Republic
right now. Yeah. Go on.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. Uh Trump's a very
strange character. He's very erratic and
I can't understand him at all. I don't I
don't pretend to understand him. The
Democrats at least they seem
understandable that they are they've got
this big constituency that hates Israel
that is the uh uh the you know the the
three congress the three congressw women
Tleb and Ilhan Omar and AOC and so on
and they have to plate them but the
Republicans I don't get because Trump
came in saying he was completely in
favor of Israel he's maintained that as
a rhetorical stance, but he has gone
back on it very severely. Not only by
stopping them from taking out Kamina.
Not only that, but also at the very
beginning of his second administration
when he uh made them agree to that
hostage deal where they got a few of the
hostages back in exchange for all these
murderers and terrorists that are free
now because of Trump. And so Trump, it
seems like he wants to be known as the
peacemaker, the guy who ends the wars
because he campaigned against the
endless wars. And that's good. It's it's
it's stupid for the United States to
waste its resources on these endless
conflicts with no resolution that end up
with a defeat like in Afghanistan and
Iraq.
>> Oh. Oh, did we lose Robert? Guys, do you
have me? I think we lost Robert for a
second.
Am I frozen, guys? Or is this just
Robert?
I think we're going to wait for Robert
to get fixed. Guys, am I okay? You guys
might have my audio.
>> Yeah. Seemed like everything went black
there for a bit, but
>> Oh, okay. There you go. You're back.
You're back. You're back. Oh, frozen
again.
Oh, frozen again.
We lost him.
Okay, I'm good. I'm good. So, while we
wait for Robert,
guys. Oh. Oh, you're back. You're back.
Okay. Fantastic. Sorry. But
>> yeah, I don't know what's going on. But
anyway, uh Trump's completely erratic.
He seems to want peace at all costs,
which means even stopping Israel from
defeating the jihadis in a way that
would set the jihad back decades, if not
centuries. The jihad's never going to
end. know that because as long as
they're believers, they'll be jihadis
because the the jihadis read the book
and they see what Muhammad did and some
of them become that is Muslims read the
book, some of them become jihadis. In
any case, the thing about Trump is he
doesn't have any he doesn't have any
idea of that. He doesn't have any
understanding of that. And so he thinks
that they can make some kind of a deal
because that's what he he's a
businessman who makes deals and then
there'll be peace and he's unfortunately
is just going to enable the jihadis to
continue because as Naim Kasim said
survival is a victory that they continue
so they can gather strength and fight
again later.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think what many people
including Trump don't understand is that
I mean Israel understands this is that
you get longlasting peace by crushing
your enemies, not by signing papers, not
by agreements, not by appeasements.
Longlasting peace comes through uh war
and a successful war. Every time Israel
managed to get long-lasting peace, it
wasn't because it was it was after they
absolutely crushed the people who meant
to do them harm. That's how you get
long-lasting peace, not with ceasefire,
but by destroying the people that And
again, you're right because this is in
their DNA. The whole every they look at
ceasefires as a way to regroup, recover,
rearm, retrain. That's what they did.
They don't look at it as a way to just
stop the war. Um
>> law. You only conclude a treaty with
non-Muslims when you're losing and you
need time to gather strength to beat
them later.
>> Right. Right. Right. I mean u this is
the way I based on what I've studied
this is the way I look at it and also
because I grew up in Iran um how you
know I lived there for 20 years so and
this was
>> huh
>> where what city
and
>> Oh wonderful
>> Shiraz
>> every time I uh I have some wine Shiraz
wine I think Iran used to be a place
that actually made this did they come
from that?
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. You're right. Yeah. Yeah.
Um so yeah I mean throughout my
childhood we were always told that the
eventual we will like this the regime
will eventual this I say we because they
grouped us in with them that it will one
day destroy Israel and one day the
United States and that's the goal and
that's the purpose and a lot of people
don't understand why for example when we
look at the Islamic Republic and IRGC
they consider themselves to be
revolutionary and I think many people
didn't don't ask themselves why are they
revolutionary the revolution ended did
like they were the victors of the 1979
Islamic revolution. So usually when
people are revolutionary when they get
the government they're not revolutionary
anymore. But I think what the people
don't understand was that the revolution
was not against the pah leav dynasty.
The revolution was against the world
liberal order and it has three phases.
So the first phase was a pah levi to get
Iran to use the resources of Iran to
then get the middle east. So the pah
levi was in their way in Iran. Israel is
in their way in the Middle East. So they
need to remove Israel to get the Middle
East and the final boss is the United
States. I mean many people don't
understand the version of 12 Shia Islam
in Iran was impacted by Muslim
Brotherhoods coming through to Iran
through Navi and you know the Muslim
Brotherhood didn't wasn't successful
into creating an Islamic block. So we
had three attempts. The Pan-Arabus block
against the West failed because of
Israel. Um and then we had the Sunni
Islamic block against Israel that
failed. And now we're attempting a third
time a Shia emit instead of a Sunni
caliphate, a Shia emat block against the
West. And is just like Pathi was seen as
an agent of the Western powers in Iran.
Israel is seen as an agent of the
Western powers in the Middle East. So
the phase two is to remove Israel to
then get to the United States and the
rest of the West. And that's why people
don't understand that this is all they
want to do. So this is that's why you
can't negotiate with them because you
can't remove this from their ideology.
Do you agree with that?
>> It's so important and this is something
that people in the west routinely
ignore. Uh I see so many times the
supreme leader or the president or some
top mullah and they are saying exactly
what you're saying that this is a global
revolution. We're taking this revolution
everywhere. We're going to destroy
Israel. We're going to destroy the
United States so that we can bring the
Islamic revolution to the West
ultimately. And people think, well,
that's crazy. Iran can't defeat the
United States. Of course, they're not
talking about going to war in some
conventional fashion and having their
military go up against our military.
It's a much different kind of war. And
yet no policy analysts or diplomats or
people of that nature anywhere in the
West pay any attention to these
statements and they routinely discount
them and they treat the Islamic Republic
as if it were a secular state that has
the same motives and goals as any other
secular state. And then no, nobody in
the State Department, I would wager, not
a single person, has any idea of the 12
or Shiite theology or its political
implications.
>> Would you agree that they are the
Islamic Republic right now is the
greatest evil and the greatest threat to
the world and the stability and the
order that we have right now? Would you
would you agree?
>> There are there are a lot of threats to
the stability and order of the world,
but they're certainly way up there. uh
the the people's republic of China is I
think also a very big threat in terms of
spreading uh authoritarianism
by means of Chinese economic hegemony
that will lead to political hegemony
that could cause a lot of trouble for
the future. That's something that
actually they could work with the
Islamic Republic on. Would not be a
surprise at all because of the global
leftist Islamic alliance. Uh we see that
with the Islamic Republic funding groups
such as the communists in Spain and uh
leftist groups in Venezuela as well, the
Venezuelan government for that matter,
that they see themselves as having
similar views, similar goals in mind.
And so they're happy to work together. I
think ultimately that alliance will
break up just as Kmeni put the
communists in Iran in prison after he
had they had helped him gain power in
1979.
Uh the the left thing happening
>> and executed like thousands of them.
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. And they thought they were
going to share power.
>> Oh yeah. I mean this happens every time.
>> Yeah. Every time the leftist unites with
the Islam with the you know Muslim
forces and what the leftist bring to the
table is political knowhow and
networking and access to academic
centers. This happened to this is how I
lost we we Iranians lost our country and
the is the Muslim the Muslim people come
with their mosques and their network in
so the leftist come with their networks
in the elite the Muslims come with their
networks into the you know other people
like the people in the bazaars or the
people in the mosques h but the Muslims
will bring something that the leftists
don't have on the table which is the
brute force and the violence so they
complete each other but as soon as they
win then the Muslim forces. I I'm trying
not to say Islamist because I don't see
any difference between Islamist and
Islam. Uh you know, but as soon as they
come into power, then they realize that
oh, we don't need a leftist anymore and
they just wiped them out every single
time.
>> Right? So, and this is and this is why
we Iranians should be warning the Europe
right now because we lost we lost a
country to the unity and our king
Muhammad warned the world more than 40
years ago. He called it the unholy
alliance of red and black. Black being
Shia, red being the communist. And so I
think we're good.
>> We can warn the West all we want about
this, but if it weren't for France, then
Kmeni would never have been there ready
to take power in 1979. But they
sheltered him, they protected him, they
aided him, they brought him back to
Tehran.
and and now they this is why a lot of
people in Iran hates the influence of
the French government and even today
they're the main voices against regime
change in Iran right now uh which is a
shame which is like um a lot of this is
not good but a lot of Iranians when they
see Islamism or Islam I shouldn't say
that Islamic forces rising in France
some of them are happy they're like
here's a taste of your own medicine like
you did this like I hope Islam takes
over your country again French people
that's not what I think I'm just saying
some Iranians they're so bitter over the
fact that France helped Iran becoming an
Islamic country that they think like
maybe France deserves becoming Islamic
as well because that's what they did to
us again that's not fair to many French
people
>> it might not be but it's understandable
why they would feel this way because
they feel like the supposed free world
betrayed us and now the country our
country's been enslaved slaved for 45
years as a result and so right I I
wouldn't wish that on anybody but I
certainly understand the feeling
>> right so regarding you know you
mentioned China so I I don't know if you
agree I consider the enemies of you know
west the west to be China I mean not
China CCP Putin North Korea's government
and the Islamic Republic right so these
are the four but I think among all four
of them only the only it's only the
Islamic Republic that has the ambition
to take over the whole world like even
the rest of them I mean Russia wants to
take over Eastern Europe North Korea you
know doesn't have any ambition beyond
you know it neighborhood um and China I
think China is b even though they're
causing the CCP is causing so many
problems around the world I think
they're benefiting so much from the
order from the world order that has been
created since World War II economically
that as you know they don't want to see
it collapse it's only the Islamic
Republic that is actually fully invested
in seeing this whole thing collapse.
>> Um, that's why I see them as not maybe
as powerful, more powerful than the rest
of them, but actually the most dangerous
one. That's why I think that they're
they're the top of the list. So,
>> would you Yeah, go on. Sorry.
>> No, just saying you're right. That's a
good point that uh I don't know that
China doesn't have global ambitions
because for example they're very active
in Africa where it's hard to see that
they have any real geopolitical
interests unless they have global
aspirations. But as far as uh Iran and
the Islamic Republic go, that's there's
no doubt about that whatsoever that
Islam has a global imperative and they
consider themselves to be the exponents
of it today. So this is uh this is
something that unfortunately nobody in
the west is paying any attention to, but
it's very real. Would you agree that um
supporting Israel right now is
supporting the entire world? Because
Israel is paying the heavy price more
than other countries like it's doing
what other countries should be doing as
well. But Israel is paying the heavy
price for it. Um standing between the
world and its enemies and the more we
support Israel today, the more basically
we're supporting this evil spreading in
to the rest of the world. Do you think
that's an exaggeration or you think
that's fair? I think that's spot on,
Armen. And look at uh what you were just
saying that the Islamic Republic has
global aspirations and those come out of
Islam and they're believers in Islam all
over the world and among those believers
are some who think that it's their
responsibility to to advance the
interests of the believers and gain
their dominance over the non-believers
because this is what the Quran and
Muhammad command. And so Israel is on
the front lines of the defense against
that. People don't realize it's the same
struggle and that we are all in their
sights as well, but we are. And so
Israel is doing a job for the entire
world.
>> What about supporting the Iranian people
and also supporting the recent surge in
unity between the Iranian people and
Israeli people? I mean even before
October 7th we saw many videos from Iran
people refusing to step on Israel's flag
um I don't know if you've seen the
videos those are famous where the
Islamic Republic will paint Israel's
flags on the on the ground and many
people hundreds of people will go around
and refusing to step on it so that was
just respect but now it's turn respect
has turned to actual admiration and very
heavy support and that's growing in Iran
and I given
I will just quickly say the way I look
at it and see if you agree because I
think the Iranian people and Israeli
people complete each other because
Iranian people are unarmed. Israel has
the best weapons and they really know
how to use it. However, what Israel
lacks is boots on the ground. Um and if
you want to topple the Islamic Republic,
you need presence of people there to
capture the building, capture the
institutions, capture the military
bases. Um, and Israel obviously nobody
else is going to do this where like
United States is not going to come to
Iran and have boots on the ground.
Israel doesn't share a border with Iran.
Israel might have been is able to send
soldiers into Gaza or to Lebanon or to
Syria, but Israel Iran is so big, is so
wide, and is far away and they don't
have enough manpower to do something
that and that is required. So, but the
boots on the ground are the Iranian
people. So I think the Iranian people
and Israeli people if they cooperate
with each other they both are uh comp
they complete each other they both are
providing what the other ones lacks. So
and again if ending the Islamic Republic
is so important for the future of the
world I think building this bridge and
supporting this unity is the key here.
Would you agree with that?
>> Oh absolutely 100%. Uh the Iranian
people have to be the ones who topple
the Islamic Republic. Nobody else can do
it. And it's very difficult, as you
know, because the Islamic Republic is so
ruthless and crushes any sign, anything
close to a sign of disscent. They just
arrested 120 thou 120,000 people on
suspicion of spying for Israel, which is
so ridiculous that I'm sure there are
spies for Israel among the population in
Iran, but it looks as if they're just
arresting everybody they can and trying
to hope that they find some spies in the
process. And so it has to be yes some
kind of an operation where the Iranian
people get what they need to topple the
Islamic Republic from Israel and ideally
from the United States. And this is
something this is very delicate. you
know, uh, ordinarily I would say, well,
the CIA is something that I'd like to
see shut down and all the records opened
and we see exactly what they've been up
to all these years. But if we can't shut
it down, then let's use it for good for
once and help the people in Iran uh, get
what they need to topple the Islamic
Republic. And that's the kind of thing
they've been engaged in all over the
world. I don't know why they could
couldn't do it there. But in any case,
uh it it is certainly I mean obviously
you're right. The Israelis can't send
troops and shouldn't send troops into
Iran and nor should the Americans, but
all we do need to be figuring out ways
somehow to aid the people there to get
rid of the regime. And it's very clear
everybody hates the regime in Iran. It
wouldn't last long if the people had the
resources to topple it.
I mean, to your point, when it comes to
the number of arrests, it's not just
that they're hoping to get some spies,
it's also because they use it as a way
to scare everyone else. Like I my
friends in Iran, they when they see so
many people being arrested just for
liking or like some people who even
criticize the government for their
handling of the situation during the 12
of the war, they have been arrested for
for being spies of Israel. Like I was
just telling like they weren't they
didn't even say anything about Israel
and they're still getting arrested. But
that that's just the way I mean the
Islamic Republic has become really good
at only one thing. They they suck at
everything else and that's oppressing
and oppressing their own people. They
have mastered that art. Um and that's
why a lot of people say, "Oh, why
haven't the Iranian people risen up
after the 12 day war? They don't
understand how good the Iranian people
have came out many, many times and they
paid the heaviest price for it." The
Islamic Republic doesn't just kill
people, doesn't just torture people,
doesn't just blind people. They also
torture your family. They also use rape
in prison. Rape in prison against both
men and women after they arrested as a
way to and they make sure that other
people find out. There are so many
people who have been released from the
Islamic Republic's prisons. people who
were so brave and they were willing to
die to free Iran. But then what they did
to them made them come and end their
life after they were released. Uh
because the Islamic Republic knows that
so many Iranian people are brave. So
they have to scare them with something
worse than death to get the Iranian
people silenced. And also recently the
Islamic Republic has gotten really good.
Like last time people were considering
coming out. As soon as they came into
the streets, the streets were filled
with anti-right police. Heavily geared,
heavily armed, armored vehicles. There
were more soldiers than people. For
every person in the street, there were
three soldiers. And everybody
understands that as soon as I chant, I'm
going to get completely crushed and
defeated. So, I think a lot of people
who are waiting for the Iranian people
now to rise up don't understand what the
situation right now is in Iran is. And
what Israel could do, and they were
about to do this at the end of the 12-
day war, they were starting to. They
could take out the people the main
decision makers because they already
took out the main decision makers when
it comes to attacking Israel, but they
could also now take out the main
decision makers when it comes to
controlling the anti- riot forces and
you know their their their bases,
destroying their bases, destroying their
base of operation and all the resources
they have. If they do that, then they
and also if they tell the Iranian people
that if you come into the streets and we
see anti-ri, we will target the
anti-right police. If they say that,
then a lot of pe Iranian people will see
that as a way and I hope they actually
deliver on that promise because right
now they say we're going to support the
Iranian people but I think it needs to
be clear that it's going to be a
military support with with drones with I
don't know missiles when the people
Iranian people go face to face with the
uh with their oppressors. That's what I
think it's needed to topple the regime.
But I don't know. I think Yeah. Do you
agree with that? That was brilliant to
me that they if they could take out the
people who are make constructing all
these instruments of oppression and
making it impossible for demonstrations
to take place and torturing and killing
the people who demonstrate then that
would be the end of the Islamic Republic
and so uh you know they got uh Ismael
Hane and so can happen.
>> Yes. Yes. Um I mean they did they were
starting to do that at the end of the 12
day war and then Trump stopped it and
Trump stopped Another thing that the
world could do. I I don't know what what
you think about this. By the way guys I
will read your super chat at the end but
um another thing that the that they
could do is to recognize Resopi. Yeah
>> because Resza Palvi you agree with that?
Okay let me know what you think about
>> Yeah. Because see, there's somebody
who's already got a big base of support
within Iran, and he's already said he
won't come in and just assume he's going
to be the sha and reign until he dies.
But he will come in and oversee things
so that there's an orderly transition
until there's Iranian people choose the
kind of government that they want. What
What could be the problem with that? And
there's somebody, you know, have you
seen the videos, I'm sure you've seen
more than I have, of the stadiums full
of people and they're chanting long live
res. And and so his grandson is just the
guy to send in and the one to who could
be uh a stabilizing force in the
post-Islamic Republic period.
Well, I mean I I don't know now that you
mentioned stadium solar people
mentioning there is even more chance.
Let me actually tell you about two other
chats. Okay. So that chant that they say
long live Rosa. We actually now have
chance talking about mentioning Rzza
Palvi himself saying King Riza Palvi and
also one of the more favorite chants now
are
which means Iran is ready now give us to
order our prince but another chant that
I don't know if you've seen that was is
very popular in stadiums
um I is this can I show it to you
because I think you might enjoy this one
if if you haven't seen it. Hold on.
And this is guys, this is in Iran. And
so I don't know if you understand how
and this how risk how much of risk these
people are taking. I think you're going
to enjoy this. Hold on. And I could
actually tell you that the translation
is correct. So let me actually play
this.
[Applause]
That's an entire stadium of Iranians
inside Iran chanting, "Shove the
Palestinian flag up your ass." And I
don't know people I don't know if people
understand what big of the fact that
this is coming from inside Iran, how big
it is. And also recently we had another
um stadium basically the entire stadium
chanting that and the Iranian national
TV was broadcasting that football uh
game live so the the guy was trying to
speak over it so that people could not
hear it on TV at their homes. But what
do you think about that? Did you have
you seen this chant? No, I haven't seen
that.
>> That's very And I have seen many
indications that the Iranian people are
fed up with the regime's support for
Hisbala, for Hamas, for all of them. And
they have chanted, they have
demonstrated saying you should not, you
should be taking care of your own people
and not sending all the money over to
these jihadis abroad. And so this is
something that's been building for a
long time.
>> Yep. Many Iranian people when they hear
the name Palestine, they get they feel
nothing but rage because this whole the
whole Palest Palestinian cause is the
main reason for their government uh to
do everything that it's doing like all
the resources that has been wasted all
the you know a terrorist attacks that
they do everything that they do is for
the sake of something that has nothing
to do with Iran has nothing to do with
the Iranian people. So that's why so
many Iranian people when they hear the
name Palestine, they start swearing.
They start swearing. Oh, by the way, you
might like this as well. There's another
thing a chant in Iran, they say Ham
Islam, Hamuran
Islam. They say both Islam and the Quran
sacrifice both of them for the sake of
Iran. Um, one thing that I don't agree
with that some Iranians say is that no
no Muslim is Iranian and no Iranian is
Muslim. Meaning I I don't agree with
that because I think legally if you are
a citizen of a country, you're a citizen
of a country. But I'm just trying to
show you the attitudes people have that
if you have decided to be a Muslim,
you're not a real Iranian. That
>> there is a lot of hypocrisy.
>> Uh I'm sure you know about the the what
is it? Gam the survey that was from a
couple years ago and only 40% of people
in Iran still say they're Muslim.
>> And that's supposed to be 99% Muslim.
But now they're so disgusted with the
Islamic Republic that most people are
willing to tell a survey that they're
they they have left Islam.
>> Yes. And it's an that was an academic
poll and that shows within 40 years we
have had the greatest mass exodus of out
of a religion.
>> Yes.
>> With in the history of the world.
Basically half of Iranians within their
lifetime has left a religion. This has
never happened in history within 40
years. in one lifetime. Um, this is why
I think like the Iranian people are the
greatest force against Islam because I
think you will not find more hatred for
Islam in any country more than in Iran.
>> Yeah.
>> Um, yeah. So, I think a lot of people
think that we're
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, I'm just agreeing. You're absolutely
right. In West people have been
propagandized for 25 years or more all
about how Islam is a religion of peace
and Islamophobia is a big problem. But
in Iran, they know better because they
experience Islam, the real thing, all
the time. And they have the memory of
what life was like without it when the
sha was there. And so they don't like
Islam very much at all.
>> What do you think about the Iranian
Muslims who are anti-government? Because
in Iran, we we we tell them that listen,
we disagree on Islam, but we are trying
to bring a a secular Iran. like we will
uh we're not trying to eliminate you.
We're trying to when Iran becomes
secular, you could, you know, advertise
Islam as long as we're also free to
advertise against Islam. But a lot of
Iranians are saying some Iranians who
are also anti-Islam tell us that maybe
we should stop with the anti-Islamic
rhetoric because we also have some
allies who are Muslims against the
Islamic Republic and we don't want to
lose them. But I I I don't Yeah.
>> I mean, I'm asking you what what do they
want? Do they want an Islamic Republic
that's sweeter?
>> What do they
>> No, no, no. They want So Mo the the same
polls that you you mentioned shows
actually that even most Muslims in Iran
want a secular Iran. Even Muslims.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, then there's problem with aligning
with them.
>> Yeah. But they say that so they tell us
that okay if you keep advertising
against Islam they're going to think
that a secular Iran means in Iran that
we will come and hunt down the Muslims
right and we're trying to tell them like
no it just means that you are free to
advertise Islam and we are free to
advertise against Islam that's all it
means you could go
>> is the one with the death penalty for
apostasy
nobody's saying if you become a Muslim
we'll kill you nobody says that but the
Isl Islam says, "If you leave Islam,
we'll kill you." And so what the what
the people what you should be telling
them is all we want is that you're not
hunting us down for not being Muslim
anymore.
>> But they think but some of them think
and it's less and less right now. Like a
lot of Muslims in Iran have accepted the
fact that so many Iranians are
anti-Islam and they are like this is
just the normal now. But some of them
think that because how bad Islam was to
us, we are going to do the same thing to
Muslims.
>> Yes.
>> Once we get the upper hand, once we win
I mean I have frame of reference. So
they figure everybody's behave the same
way.
>> And
if terror is the only tool of the
Islamic Republic, then the foes of the
must only operate on terror as well.
>> Right. I mean I have like Robert, you're
going to love this. I have some friends
in Iran that tell me some of their
Muslim friends tell that think that the
Islamic Republic is going to fall any
day now. They come to their non-Muslim
friends and like, "Hey guys, like please
don't shoot me. I'm with you guys."
Like, "Guys, don't shoot me. I'm like,
I'm I know I'm a Muslim, but I'm with
you guys."
>> Incredible.
>> But it's understandable. It's it's it's
very hard, you know.
It's it's it's easy relatively
speaking. I shouldn't say it's easy at
all in any context. It's it's very hard
to leave Islam because of all the
threats and all the fear that it
inculcates within people. But it's even
harder than that if you've left Islam to
get rid of all the attitudes
that it inculcates within you because a
lot of times you're not even aware and
they have them reflexively. And people
who are still Muslims but don't like the
regime, they're going to be assuming
they're going to be looking at things
through that prism. And that means yeah,
of course, they're going to assume that
you're going to be just as repressive in
reverse,
>> right? Um, it doesn't help that there
are a few people on our side that do
think that we need to be hunting moolas
down. Like there's a few, but the
Islamic Republic takes them takes their
voices and amplifies it to share its
Muslims. Um, but there are a few. It
doesn't help that there are a few that
think that okay after the Islamic
Republic fall like one thing that some
people were suggesting and again most
Iranians are against that but they were
saying that there needs to be for every
tree there needs to be a mulla like and
I'm not going to expand on what that
means basically talking about hanging
people right but again the Islamic when
the Islamic Republic loves that it takes
that and says like guys even if you're
against me you should stand with me
because look at what these people are
going to do but And that's not the that
that's a minority of people. I'm just
letting you know the full giving you the
full picture of what I'm saying.
>> Yeah. Well, it's understandable the
Islamic regime would use that
>> because they want to make people afraid
and afraid of what might happen if they
if they fall and so they they they want
to spread those ideas. So, it's
important for the opposition, such as it
is, to repudiate whenever that kind of
thing is enunciated, to repudiate it and
make it very clear that that's not what
they're about.
>> But of course, the Shaw's son is not
going to do something like that. So,
here
>> thing to bring him back.
>> Yes. And also, I know I'm not I'm not
defending this position, but I
understand why it happens also. Like
even though it's few like a lot of
people when they see that they condemn
it and I condemn it as well but they
don't understand
what price the Iranian have people have
paid uh for because of the Islamic
Republic the the the lives that have
been destroyed and why there's so much
anger. So it's only na it's not
acceptable but it's natural. It's it's
not acceptable but it's expectable for
expected to for you to see such
reactions from a country that has been
from a people that are being I mean the
poverty the the the the oppression the
the brutality has been bone crushing. So
I don't think other people could sit out
look at this from outside and judge
unless they have experienced what it is
like to live under the Islamic Republic.
>> Yeah. I'm only talking about the not
handing the enemy a weapon,
>> right? Yeah. No, no, I wasn't talking
about you. I was talking about Yeah. And
also your point regarding Ra Palvi, what
what do you think would you be able to
I'm gonna ask you in front of everybody
this would you be able to mention him
because you have a big audience and
people look up to you and people follow
your and you do great writings. Yeah.
Would you would it be able would you be
able to actually like maybe write an
article about him and why people should
be supporting him? Would you
>> I appreciate you uh thinking it would
matter. But sure
>> I can I'll write an article about that.
I wrote a book I don't know if you know
I wrote a book uh it's it's almost 10
years ago now. The complete infidel's
guide to Iran. And
>> yes
>> it's uh it's I don't know. I I I was
looking through it recently when Iran
was back in the news and I thought this
isn't that bad a book. But uh in any
case, I'm only saying just that uh in
order to get that book together, I
studied a good bit about Iran and so I
could write an article about uh the the
prince and call for his return.
>> No problem.
>> Oh my god. Thank you so much. Well,
these are the like I know about that
book, but these are the books of you
that I have read. By the way, guys, you
should read these books. Actually, you
have two. This one is outdated. You have
another version, right?
>> Yeah, I uh revised it a few years ago
because there was so much more. So, I
added some things and expanded the book
a bit. And this is the addition that you
can get now.
>> The one you've got is gone. And also I
wrote another book last year that is a
biography of Muhammad goes through the
stories from the hadith and sir
literature and compares different
versions and shows how it's all uh it's
all made up essentially and their
variance in the stories just as you
would expect from legendary development.
Yeah, I was telling I was telling Robert
guys before we went live that I I mean
even on this channel I have turned the
things that I learned from this book
into content for you guys and you guys
loved it. But in Iran I also on my
Persian channel for my Iranian audience
and I mean it's I have to be fair. It's
not just Iranian audience because there
are some people from Afghanistan who
speak Persian, some people from
Tajikistan and other places who speak
Persian as well but my audience is
mostly Iranian, right? Um, and they love
the your the content from your book that
I turn into videos. I mean, I was hoping
that like is is that is that okay that I
turn it into videos because um is it
because it's copyrighted that I just use
it uh to Okay, I have your permission to
make it into video.
>> Thing I would add is you say where you
got it. So, mention the book at
>> Yeah, I do.
>> I do. I do. I mention it multiple times.
I mention it multiple times. That's to
get the information out there. So, I
appreciate it. Thank you.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. People are people are in
love with the content on the Persian
side and the content from your book. So,
have it has it been translated into
Persian? Because I really think this is
like the main nail into the coffin for
Islam. Like this is all you need. Like I
don't think this is this is like the
evidence that you provide in this book
for why all of the story is the say
stories are made up is undeniable.
I'll send you if you let me know where
to send it, I'll send you the new
version uh after the show. But anyway,
um the the translation is very
complicated because unfortunately I have
to that's part of the contract that the
publisher takes care of that and the
publisher wants to deal with another
publisher and there's no publisher in
Iran
>> that is going to publish this book of
course but it could happen under the
under the radar behind the scenes. If
anybody wants to do it please do. I hope
you have the translation accurate. I
don't know, Farscy. I can't tell. But,
uh, go ahead, do make do your best and
spread it around as much as you can in
Iran. And thank you.
>> Nice.
would you agree that this is the way to
basically
I mean to to fight Islam because I think
because a lot of people all the
arguments for um you know why these
teachings of Islam are wrong if it had
like it's already out there like people
the information is accessible I think
there's not much more we could do to say
I mean if you're not convinced by why
it's not okay for somebody to have sex
with a nine-year-old. Um, I mean, I
don't know what else to tell you, right?
So, like that is that is like there's
not much more you could do on that
front. So, I think this is the new front
that we could actually try at different
angle. This is
>> Yeah, I uh totally agree. Obviously, uh
having written two and a half books on
it. So, um or one and a half. No, two
and a half. Yeah, because I revised that
one and then wrote the other. So in any
case, uh yeah, I think that it's an
approach. I've noticed something that
the Islamic apologists on YouTube, I
don't do a whole lot of videos myself
where I'm speaking, you know, I'm guests
on shows, but sometimes I do videos. But
the point is I know there's this whole
community here and people who do videos
about Islam on both sides and there are
the Dagandists, the Dawa people who
spread Islam and then the people who are
Christians or atheists or whatever and
they reply to them and it goes back and
forth and I see a lot of discussion
about like Aisha being a child and all
those things that have been discussed
for years but the Islamic apologists as
far as I know they don't have any answer
to this about
Muhammad not existing and the stories
being fictional. They've never heard
these arguments. They don't have any way
to reply. They assumed that it was all
things like people Muhammad talking and
people writing everything down and it's
not uh they so I think it it's it can be
very powerful. Yes. But there's a lot of
confusion also, I have to say, because
there are critics of Islam
>> who I respect a great deal who think,
"Oh, this is terrible. You shouldn't be
talking this way." Because then that's
that'll be the easy way for them to say,
"Oh, I wasn't a child. You're just
saying it's a madeup story. It never
happened." Well, that's that's not the
point. The stories say what they say.
And Muslims right
>> and so we have to know what they say and
criticize them on that basis. And they
do say Aisha was a child. So we have to
hit them on that basis. There's no doubt
about that. But at the same time, a
second level of the argument is that
these stories were fabricated for
political reasons. And so people may
have made up this Aisha stories because
they wanted to engage in child marriage
and so on. Uh but that uh the historical
value does not change the fact that this
is something that is in the Islamic
texts about Muhammad.
Right. That that's the way I look at it.
I think every single Quranic verse and
every single hadith line was there
because it served somebody. There was
somebody some at some point that it
gained some utility from this. That's
why they added that line somewhere. So
yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I mean it's a beautiful
mystery to solve because if you look at
I mean actually enjoy Islam this way
because it's it looks like a box of
enigma because like okay this hadith
>> why the hell somebody would write this
like what what political advantage what
economic advantage like many most of it
hasn't been if you look at it from an
evolutionary perspective like the
evolution of this meme of Islam if you
try to dissect every single line then
it's like a det very interesting
detective work that you have to go
through that is
>> yeah and uh I did some of that in this
book and that's the idea of this like
why were these things invented what is
the whole idea here and you know uh
>> it's well it it also takes care of the
whole argument that I think is the
strongest argument for the accuracy of
the texts that some of these stories are
so embarrassing they never would have
made them up. Uh and that's true.
>> Zena that was the most fascinating part
of the book. The story of Zay. I tell
that story everywhere after I read this
in this book. The actual utility is to
show Muhammad was the via the last of
the seal of the prophet. That was the
point of the story. That was beautiful.
I every time I get a chance, I repeat
that part of that part from this book.
And you see there's no way to explain
chapter 33 of the Quran. Otherwise, why
does it say the seal of the prophets
right there after it mentioned Zade and
the whole story of Zanab? Unless it's a
it's because of that.
>> There's no other just a nonsequittor.
It's that it just changes the subject
without warning, which the Quran does a
lot. But if you can see why there is
something that makes sense, there's no
reason to reject that.
>> You know, you mentioned some people was,
you know, I think you mentioned people
like David Wood who would say that we
should this, you know, we fighting Islam
and Muhammad.
>> Sorry.
>> And this would and if you basically try
to dismiss all of these stories, then
what are we fighting against? Um I the
the example I give I don't know if you
think this is a good example.
>> Sorry about that. But I thought my
ringer was off.
>> Oh, no worries. That's fine. Um, the
example I give usually and is I could
look at I could read Harry Potter and
say Voldemort is an evil character.
>> I mean, people wouldn't deny like I
don't think people like, "Oh, Harmen,
how could you say Voldemort is evil?
Don't you know that this is fiction?"
Yeah. But
>> that's it.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. So, you think that's a
good example? Okay.
>> Yeah. I studied Shakespeare in college
and so we read McBth and we had to talk
about what did McBth do, what did he say
here, what did he do there and nobody
ever said, "Wait a minute, McBth didn't
do anything. He was fictional." And so
it's very it's it's exactly like that
that all these things are are stories
designed to make various points for
various Islamic factions and they're put
together for that reason. And that does
not mean that Muslims don't believe them
and act upon them. And we have to know
that. But does that does that in it that
in turn doesn't mean that they're they
really happen.
>> Okay. So I'm going to ask one last
question. But after I ask my last
question, would it be uh would you have
time to we have six super chats. Would I
be able to go through them with you? I
know you've been very generous with your
time, so I'm not going to keep you. So
my last question is a challenging one
regarding, you know, so we're against
Islam. Uh but we have Muslims, many
Muslims who are good people. Um um I
think me and you would agree the reason
why they're good people is because
they're not following Islam thankfully.
Right. Um um however I mean maybe there
and they will say no I am following
Islam but we think that their reading of
Islam is is incorrect and we I think
that these are people who are better
than Islam right even though they might
not agree with that. Uh how are these
Muslims who are good people
um if they're fighting the same fight
for reasons that you know they might
think it's compatible with Islam but we
think it's not um would you consider
them as allies
>> if they are fight absolutely okay
>> yeah you know I've said that uh for for
20ome years now I started jihadwatch uh
jihadwatch.org which is a news site
about jihad activity in October 2003.
And so that's almost 22 years now. And
in there I say I think it still says it
somewhere in the material explaining
what the site's for and so on that any
Muslim who renounces jihad, renounces
all this supremacism and oppression is
we're we're happy to work with you. But
uh nobody's ever taken me up on that
>> except one. the late Tashbi Sed who used
to be a member of the Jihad Watch board
and he he he was a Muslim and he uh was
a reformist, a genuine reformist who
spoke about how they had to challenge
the idea of Muhammad as the perfect
example and so on and so I uh pay
tribute to him. I'm happy to report to
you that I have been working with Muslim
Iranians who know I am aggressively
anti-Islam
and I also have been working with this
man called his name is Measeri and he
used to work directly for harmony. He
was his media arm.
>> Oh wow.
>> Um yeah in he's in Canada now. They're
trying to kick him out of Canada so back
to Iran even though he's anti-regime. He
the the leftists are after him. um his
his his
name he's he's still a Muslim and he he
is he's Muslim and he is religious but
he has accepted anti-Islam activists as
his ally against Islamic Republic and
he's very friendly towards us and we and
we he understands that anti-Islam
activism doesn't mean anti-Muslim
activism he understands that and
>> very important distinction and they the
the western Islamic apologists and the
leftists do their best to elide that and
obscure that distinction. And this is
very insidious because they want to
portray criticism of Islam as being
anti-Muslim, which everybody, you know,
why should why would you be against any
group of people? That sounds terrible.
And so you like, you look me up on
Wikipedia, it says I'm an anti-Muslim
activist. And I've always denied being
anti- anyone. I am talking about an
ideology. I'm not talking about people.
But they always if anybody takes it out,
they put it back because it's part of
the propaganda campaign to discredit
opposition to Islam.
>> In fact, if I usually say, I don't know
if you agree with this, uh, Muslims,
we're anti-Islam partly for the sake of
Muslims because Muslims are the first
victims of Islam.
>> Yes,
>> Muslims are the first victim of Islam.
Okay. And also you might want to look
into meth because leftists are trying to
leftists who are against Rosa Pali are
trying to kick him out of Canada so that
he goes back to Iran and get persecuted
by the Islamic Republic. But they they
are pretending that they want to kick
him out of Canada because he used to
work with the Islamic Republic. But the
only reason why they're trying to kick
him out of Canada is because he's
supporting Resop Pali now. And the the
left Iranian leftists are anti-Israel
and anti-res. And that's the reason the
real reason what they're trying to
talking about. Yeah, totally correct.
>> Right. Um, okay. I'm not going to I'm
really quickly going to go over the
super chat. Um, again, so I'm going to
try to do it quick because I know you've
been very generous with your time. James
is saying, oh, let me highlight it
again. James is saying, I agree Islam is
a threat, but ADL calls you a bigot and
conspiracies. How do you respond and
ensure uh your ensure your critique is
fair and not bigoted or racist? I think
we just answered that question, right?
>> Yeah. ADL is not a not an honest broker
in this. Uh fact is I would challenge
anybody to go through I've written 32
books. I've written thousands of
articles. I've written 50 60,000 blog
posts at Jihad Watch. Find one that is
racist. Find one that's bigoted. Find
one that says, "Oh, because Muslims are
what? Arab? What what is it? What's it
supposed to be? I mean, Arman's not an
Arab. Uh, so what's it supposed to be?
Anti- what? Which race? But if if you
pick a race and say I hate it, find me
hating it.
>> Find me saying something like this.
There isn't anything like this. These
these are charges that have no basis
that are used in like I just said, so
I'm repeating myself now. Sorry, but
that are used to discredit the whole
opposition to jihad violence and the
oppression that comes from Sharia.
In fact, not only you're not anti-Arab,
you actually work with anti-Islamic
Arabs a lot. They're the anti-Islam
activism has grown among Arabs. I mean,
just go look at the Arabic YouTube. The
anti-Islamic content is growing so
faster than any other anti-Islamic
content I've ever seen. So, that's
another people. Yeah.
>> Um, and Sean is saying, "American
America's blind spot is that we view
everything through the lens of freedom
and opportunity. Not everything is
motivated by that.
>> Very important. You're absolutely right,
Shauna.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Um I just don't want to
generalize all Americans, but I see your
point. Um El is saying France is
responsible for a lot. Look at Africa. I
mean,
>> that was a different time. I don't know
if Africa, it's fair to blame France. I
think I could blame France now for
what's happening in Iran because they
continue to do that. But I don't want to
blame France now for what's h for what
they did before in Africa because that
was a different France. Do you think
that's fair?
>> France now that was fighting the uh
al-Qaeda groups in Mali and in that
general area in West Africa and then cut
and run. And so now the jihadis are
gaining everywhere and they're defeating
the national armies. It's a very serious
situation and it's only going to get
worse.
>> So I'm not a fan of France myself.
Okay, I don't want to blame France
entirely because I know there's a lot of
very anti-Islamic
French people that would not be want to
I don't want to journal I don't want to
>> yeah the
>> the see the thing is here again we have
the problem between the west and the
Islamic world that the west thinks of a
war as okay we'll fight a war for two or
three years or whatever and then it ends
and the jihad never ends. So the French,
they think, "We're tired of fighting in
West Africa. We're going to bring our
troops home." And that's reasonable.
That's understandable. But meanwhile,
the jihad continues. And so, uh, it
never ends. And I suppose I shouldn't
blame the French for not wanting to
fight it forever, but somebody's going
to have to deal with it or the free
societies in the West are going to be
destroyed ultimately.
Um, and Jean is saying, "Hello from
Robert's probably only non-binary fan."
Shalom.
>> Hello, only non-binary fan.
>> Jean is non-binary in Israel. Well,
thank you, Jean, for the super chat. Um,
and then we have um I don't know how to
pronounce your name. Say, "Trump stop
regime change in Iran to save the
Abraims. Do you do you see a way for
both to succeed? If no, which is more
important for peace in the Middle East?
I think Trump stopped it mostly because
of pressure from isolationist MAGA.
That's the reason why Trump stopped.
>> But the fact is at the same time if the
Islamic Republic falls, the Abraham
Accords are over because they're based
on a shared threat from Iran that the
Sunni states feel and that Israel feels.
And so if Iran's no longer a threat,
there's no need for the Abraham Accords.
And the Sunni states are already under
pressure from significant portions of
their populations because of the Abraham
Accords. And people saying, "You're
you're allying with the Jews against
Muslims. This is terrible." And so the
Abraham Accords would die if the Islamic
Republic died. But I think, well, that's
that's worth it. We need to get rid of
the Islamic Republic.
>> Well, I mean, I I don't know if you've
heard of the Citrus Accords. um
something in replace. Okay. So, Rosa
Palavi introduced the term Cyrus accords
with which would include everybody in
the Abrahamic occur and also Cyrus um
you know the Cyrus the great is the the
person that both the Jews and Persians
admire. So um that would include Iran in
there and it would be more based on
economic development and trade rather
than just military cooperation to
against Islamic Republic.
>> Bring him back.
All the more reason to bring him back.
>> Nice. Okay. So, like love to hear, you
know, I don't know if you noticed, but
every time you say something positive
about Rosa Pal, I just I'm actually so
glad that you're familiar with him and
you support him. I'm Yeah. Yeah. Um,
okay.
>> Might not be today, but certainly today
or tomorrow.
>> Oh my god. Thank you. Okay. Fantastic.
Okay. I'm looking forward to that. Sam
is saying, "Thank you, Robert, for all
your important work." Well, thank you,
Sam. And then last super chat, VA is
saying France is active in Africa now.
Yeah. Yeah. But I think Robert is
saying,
>> "Yeah,
>> they're withdrawing. They've already
withdrawn a lot of their forces and
they're going to they're cutting out
alto together." And the problem is the
jihadis are just seeing it as now we
have free reign. And so I don't, you
know, I'm not in favor of these endless
wars. And so I understand how the French
feel, but it's an intractical
obtractable problem. What are you going
to do as the jihad continues to advance
in Africa and they're better equipped?
The jihadis are better equipped and
better funded than the national
militaries. The that is really what need
that's the answer right there. Nobody
seems curious about who's funding
al-Qaeda in the Arabian not al-Qaeda in
the Arabian Peninsula. Al-Qaeda West
Africa pro uh I'm I'm sorry the Islamic
State West Africa province is and
al-Qaeda in West Africa as well. Who's
funding them? Who's equipping them? That
needs to be discovered and the money cut
off and then a lot of the problem will
melt away because they won't be able to
continue to pursue the jihad.
>> Do you know who's funding them? I don't
and I I don't see anybody even looking
into it.
>> I know the Shia groups in Africa are
being funded by the Islamic Republic. So
Islamic Republic's Yeah.
>> All right. Um Robert, I took more of
your time than I promised. So I
apologize for that and I thank you for
your generous time.
>> Guys, please again, well I know the new
version, not this one that I'm holding.
Please, please, please make sure you
check out this book. This is This book
is fascinating. It's fascinating. Please
go read it.
>> Amazon. This is the one.
>> Yes. And also check out Jihad Watch
>> revised and expanded edition there.
>> Oh. Oh, no. Okay. I need the PDF version
of that because I like to
>> send me an email. I'll send you back the
PDF.
>> Oh my god. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Um guys, also check out Jihadwatch. If
you don't know what Jihadwatch is,
you're missing out. It's a really
anybody that is trying to monitor um
Islamic activity around the world. Jihad
Watch is a really good resource. Uh
Robert is responsible for that and the
link to that website is in the
description. I know most of you already
know about it. Um OD is saying, "Thanks,
Robert." People are saying, "Thank you,
Robert." Thank you guys. All right,
Robert, I'm going to end the stream so
that you don't so I don't take more of
your time. Thank you again. Thank you so
much.
>> Talking to you.
>> Thank you. All right, talk to you soon.
Bye.
>> See you later.
>> See you.